[Music]
I'm told it's your wedding anniversary
tomorrow that's correct
all right how many thank you for
reminding me how many yeah that's my job
here is remind you how many years you've
been married we've got four years down
and forever to go all right so uh gifts
do you know what you're doing have you
gotten a gift yet ah this is my gift
just talking to you I don't quite
understand what your wife gets out of
that or frankly what you get out of me I
get to go look people do like me and
she's sort of convinced right right yeah
so you know she's her birthday we kind
of screwed this up because her birthday
was just two weeks ago right so it
happens in the same month right and it's
kind of selfish to just celebrate so
much it's her heavy so I just we're
probably just gonna watch this again hey
baby
hey honey remember when I said we're
gonna watch it well your happy
anniversary Greg what did she bring
everyone three years is silverware four
years is Conan O'Brien exactly right
actually yeah two more years you get to
go on the view
you